well guys
you have picked the coolest
independent activities period class you
could ever do with ground school this is
the most awesome thing possible when i
saw the course offerings so kudos to
tina and phil for teaching this this is
a good good gig
i go by laz it's a fighter pilot thing
all fighter pilots have call signs
they're not like what you see in the
movies by the way top gun is the worst
movie for any fighter pilot to watch
it's terrible drives you crazy no one is
called maverick because they're the most
awesome thing on the face of the planet
never happens that way
you're always named for something silly
so the previous discussion about uh crew
resource management if you're single
seat you still have air traffic control
you have other guys
i am living proof that that's 100 true
so i won't get into it too much but
suffice to say if you know the biblical
story of lazarus you know a lot about
how i got my name and i'll leave it at
that normally that's over beer
afterwards so we're here to talk about
f-22 flight control stuff i'm gonna give
you the the punch line right at the
start i'm here to tell you that
everything you're learning so who's
actually flown airplanes here already
like sail planes so a lot of guys right
so a lot of guys so first time then for
probably the other half of the class or
so
so here's what i'm here to tell you the
same stuff that you're learning with
respect to cessna's and all the stuff
with respect to the ground school
there's no difference
between this and between my beloved
raptor it's the same thing so there's
great relevance and you as mit guys have
the ability to derive and figure out
what makes the raptor look the way that
it does and we can talk a lot about the
flight controls it's not cosmic we can
go through that
so with that they always have the
standard personal background slide
here's here's a gig i'll keep it really
simple i am a test pilot
which means i am a fighter pilot and i'm
also an engineer it means i like beavis
and butthead greatly and i read carl
sagan it's the same thing to me so as a
fighter test pilot you live in the world
of being a fighter pilot but you also
have the ability to understand matlab
and to be able to do cool neat mit-ish
kind of things because all of the stuff
that you're working with as a test pilot
are brand new things new weapons new
avionics new airplanes in some cases and
that's not the world of a fighter pilot
fighter pilots are exceptionally good at
taking this airplane to combat and doing
the normal kind of missions with it but
when there's something new on board that
requires an engineer so
i have a deep deep connection with this
institution i graduated here finished up
here last year in 2018 having a whole
bunch of other kind of funky stuff along
the way
two combat tours that was a lot of fun
i'll tell you flying is one of my great
passions flying and getting shot at and
missed is my second great passion that's
much cooler
and then when you can fly and you can
use that airplane to actually protect
people from bad guys that's that's
that's life fulfilling right to go get a
chance to go do that so we can talk a
little bit more through that as well
test pilot we get a chance to fly a lot
of different stuff so you'll see this 76
different airplanes
that might sound weird to kind of the
rest of the world but in the world of
flight tests that's pretty normal and
the reason that's there is it's just
like like so i by the way warning right
to the class i talk a lot in terms of
movies right game of thrones shows
whatever television shows and sports
because no matter where you come from
those three topics always tend to bring
everybody
all together so it is just like what
you've you know when you've gone car
shopping and you sit in this car and go
oh man i really like this way the
steering wheel feels but i hate the way
the radio is set up and you go to
another car and you go oh man this is
great from a you know from the sunroof
whatever but this stinks
that same kind of
discernment that you have when you're
shopping for cars you know this airplane
is a couple hundred million dollars you
don't want to be wrong about that and so
you want your test pilots very very
experienced in a lot of different
airplanes so i've got a chance to fly
helicopters they're spectacular in pilot
training i don't know why but we send
our worst
pilot training students to helicopters
it's the dumbest idea because
helicopters are really really
challenging to go fly but we've had a
chance to fly helicopters your
discussion tina earlier about right away
i was laughing with that because i've
flown a zeppelin
an airship it it's quite spectacular
it's a big lazy boy couch
with a big trim wheel and big engines
that actually pivot on the outside so
you can turn the whole ship based on
that
that's pretty normal for for being a
test pilot is getting a chance to fly a
lot of different airplanes more so than
just one particular airplane your whole
life most of my stuff is in fighters
so i've flown every frontline fighter
with the exception of the f-35 hopefully
i'll fix that soon shortly in a few
months um but a lot of stuff so mit guy
harvard guy
did some stuff it's it's been a good
life um really at the end of the day
what i want to impress on you is
i am 100 zero different from anybody in
this room i just have more battle scars
on me just from a lifetime of doing this
uh i started off flying cessna i did
that for several years of my life i
still do it i
love it fly sail planes still do it love
it and all the stuff that you learn with
this has direct applicability to the
more advanced fighter airplanes in fact
i'll tell you
this is actually harder to fly than the
raptor and we'll talk a little bit more
about that as we go through all right so
more fun and games all right so now
comes the class participation part uh my
my talks are very interactive i love
kind of hearing what you guys think so
we'll do a quick thought exercise i'll
try and keep a mental note because i
stink at writing on a chalkboard
but we'll chat through this just so you
can understand that there's really not
that much difference from what you're
learning now to go off to do something
like that so why does a cessna look the
way that it does and why does a raptor
look the way that it does what were the
engineers trying to do and just just
call them out you know real guy just
shoot
right here okay so explain um you have
um way more area that's clear the wings
are swept in back and i kind of do all
you have to do back so we can go yeah
see all around here so you brought up
two things one is the position of the
wings right so in a cessna uh the wings
are obviously
well in a lot of airplanes really not
just cessnas but in the cessna the wings
are directly above you big hershey bar
wing you know why do they put the wings
this way in a cessna
you're doing great so far keep going man
i'm i'm gonna answer that uh get get in
or out of a cirrus in the heavy rain and
you will immediately see the value of
that cessna wing yeah they did this so
that my wife doesn't yell at me in bad
weather conditions so that you can get
inside the airplane without getting
completely wet the other part about the
high wing is it's great for visibility
looking down right
where this is terrible is if you're
turning and you have to be able to see
through the wing because you're kind of
doing the old you know looking over the
side to see uh kind of out the outside
so that's one advantage right of where
raptor right it's not a high wing or
it's kind of like a mid wing if you will
but that wing is well after the cockpit
for what reason
visibility yep
that's that's the big huge reason why
and then you also brought up the idea of
the swept wings
all right uh why the swept wings
compared to say straight wings
okay what's that what's what's that
advantage um
something that um
i'll stop picking on you because you
were bold and went first go ahead
yeah mock so so explain mock
uh fast closer you get to the speed of
sound more compressibility is important
yep uh aerodynamically the wing really
behaves
like it's going at the speed normal to
the leading edge yeah so
you ever see those old like the first
jet airplanes that came out
the wings on the jet airplanes had wings
that looked exactly like this
and that was a problem i'm going to do
something i thought i wouldn't try to do
but i'll try to do it so here's your
swept wing right here's the air as it
comes over the wing
right and then what ends up happening is
really what you care about is the air
that's going over top of the wing that's
normal to the cord line of the wing
itself you know what i mean when i say
cord right just like this imaginary line
so on a hershey bar wing all of that air
hits the wing and it goes directly over
top of that cord line of the wing so
like when we talked about over here the
wings have camber
so what happens to the air as it goes
over top of any wing it doesn't matter
if it's a fighter wing or whatever else
but what happens to the velocity of the
air as it goes over top
it goes faster right so if i'm already
going fast and air hits my wing and goes
over top of my wing and goes faster than
the rest of the airplane
that's going to cause a problem when you
get to
very high speeds approaching mach
because what ends up happening is you'll
get a shock wave forming on that wing
and the moment you get a shock wave form
in there that's like a big brick wall to
the to the wind and that causes all
types of drag downstream slows down the
airplane all types of things so what
they found is i can sweep the wing right
when i sweep the wing
some of that air is normal to the cord
line so if this is like the fuselage
over here and here's the wing and it
comes back over here
some of that air is going to be that way
and some of that air is going to
actually go out and go
go span wise if you will like this so
i'm trying to draw this correctly to get
the to get the right angles but you kind
of get my point so
some of that air goes span wise
some of the reasons why you have wing
winglets right to present prevent some
of that drag that happens at the
winglets but then also what you're
worried about is rather than the full
component of this wind you're only
worrying about the wind that's normal to
the flow
of the way the core line is set up so
that's why they sweep the wings right
okay so what else
why does the cessna look this way why
does this look like that okay
yeah good both
okay so stealth payload is an important
thing let's talk about the payload for a
second actually we'll talk about stealth
since you brought it up
um so look at that platform and what do
you notice with regards to stealth
all angles right
that angle
that angle that angle
yeah no right angles so the reason
is and i'll do
my high-tech pizza you know aid here
right
so who's who's doubly in here anyone
double e for mit okay
so if you're a beam of radar energy
you love this right you love when you
have a nice flat thing directly to
reflect so all that radar energy you put
at me goes right back at you right now
what happens if i take that panel and i
go like this a little bit right so yeah
there's not so much now really mess with
your mind what happens if i do
that right now you have to start dealing
with angles and edges right
raptor is this constant fight between
the double e guys and the aeronautical
engineers
when you make an airplane like this and
you make angles like this and you make
it there's no right angles or whatever
else like that you're exactly right it
greatly reduces the stealth now this is
not wonder woman's airplane it's not
like you just become invisible and no
one can see you but it's very very hard
to see on radar
but there's a challenge in that because
when you make an airplane that looks
like this which the double e guys tend
to like the aero engineer guys tend to
hate
because it makes the airplane unstable
so we'll talk about that
this airplane very very stable very very
stable okay what else couple other
things so why does the raptor look this
way
why does a cessna look this way
good i feel like the cessna is designed
to be produced with
cheap commodity materials yep the raptor
companies is exotic metals
titanium all types of stuff right so
this is an airplane people buy
commercially
if you had if you were jeff bezos you
would never purchase this airplane
because it is hyper expensive
my jets were test jets
which means they were very different
almost like hand-built custom f-22s each
one
three to four hundred million dollars a
piece
uh scary right in terms of how much it
actually costs the canopy on this thing
probably worth more than about 10 of
these kind of all put together
the payload part you brought a payload
too so the other part about the stealth
if you can see here i've got doors so
there's a big main weapon bay door big
17 foot doors if you will and then
there's doors on the side that come open
here
unlike a cessna i mean we talked about
you can where tina go oh she disappeared
the dropped object dropping pumpkins my
pumpkins are a thousand pounds
come off the airplane just like that
different missiles and different bombs
or whatever the center of gravity of the
airplane is right about where my finger
is and so i have these weapons that are
here that when i release them it's
suddenly like dropping a car
off the front end of your airplane and
so there's a huge center of gravity
shift that happens
just like that and so the flight
controls need to be able to compensate
for something like that last piece i'll
give you just for sake of time is what's
the speed envelope if you will that this
airplane kind of operates
man i wish 200. i would buy one right
now if i could go 200 in this thing
yeah i mean on a good day right uh you
might get you know if you get a really
really high-end general aviation
airplane 160 knots or so something like
that you can get more than that but then
you start getting into some real like
mercedes-benz exotic class kind of
general aviation airplanes that are like
the cirrus that go beyond there in
general you're talking somewhere between
80 and about 140 150 for most of them or
something like that
this airplane believe it or not this
airplane can actually fly as slow
as the cessna but it also can fly
two times the speed of sound um and it
does that pretty easily believe it or
not um also this airplane
60 degrees of bank starts to get really
extreme a little bit uncomfortable this
airplane
fully aerobatic doesn't care pulls nine
g's you guys know what g's are the
accelerations of gravity so everything
you know my human head well mit mit
heads weigh about 20 pounds or so a
little bit more than the than the norm
so at nine g's everything on your body
weighs nine times as much so that's 180
pounds with your neck has to be able to
support that imagine everything on this
airplane has to be stressed such that it
can tolerate that load and more also can
go negative g as well
altitude wise i think the highest i've
ever had a cessna was about 14 000 feet
and it was wheezing i mean it was really
really hard for it to get up there
this airplane goes zero feet all the way
up to about 60 to 65 000 feet so it
flies twice as high of what you would
see on your commercial airliners what
i'm trying to impress on you is it's a
huge flight envelope with a very
different solution set um compared to
what you might have on a cessna the only
other thing i would say with raptor is
this was something that took me a while
my first combat mission i really
understood this
in a cessna if i have a problem
i can land and most likely people will
come out to help me and call home and
let everybody know i'm okay
in bad guy land
if people are coming to get me they
really are coming to get me uh so you're
in very hostile territory where you do
not want to leave the airplane if you
can avoid it so there's a tremendous
amount of redundancy that's kind of
built into this airplane uh we'll talk
more through that a little bit so anyway
you've essentially derived all of the
challenges
that a flight control engineer would
have to deal with uh let's talk a little
bit about um
i'll put this here just for sake of
making it easy to rest
this airplane has what's called
reversible flight control system what
does that mean
you guys talked about that yet go ahead
tables or when you move yep stay here
yep so not only when you move the stick
what happens if you go outside the
airplane grab the aileron move that up
and down what happens inside the stick
moves right so it's reversible right so
i move the stick and the flight control
surfaces will deflect or i move the
flight control surfaces and the stick
will deflect so they are directly
connected with pulleys and cables to one
another um
for the guys who have flown what does
the airplane feel like when you get to
120 130 140 miles an hour i mean you're
really getting what does it feel like on
the control surfaces
yeah a lot so it gets heavy right gets
real stick kind of heavy same thing if
you're slow everything gets kind of
sloppy if you will and very because you
are directly feeling the air loads on
the airplane as transmitted to the stick
in this airplane
these flight control surfaces this this
tail surface back here is about the size
of a lot of fighter wings it's huge um
and you can imagine that 120 130 the
airplane's really hard to really move
well what happens if you're going 1 000
miles per hour you could be arnold
schwarzenegger you do not have the
strength to maneuver these controls
around so this airplane has a very very
exotic hydraulic
system and a computer system and an
electric system that allows all that to
operate from the hydraulics i'm not
kidding there's like 4 000 psi
of hydraulic fluid
that moves this whole thing around
swings it back and forth
from the electric standpoint now again
this is a reversible flight control
system all manual the flight controls in
this airplane don't work unless the
electrics are turned on to go do it
so your flight controls are electrically
controlled hydraulically powered but
electrically controlled which is a
little weird
when you think about it because now all
of a sudden electrical problems in this
airplane start impacting your ability to
fly
the airplane which gets a little bit
strange
you guys ever hear of a thing called a
permanent magnetic generator do you know
what that is a little bit of a technical
term
who knows you know a lot go ahead
is it effective is it a type of
generator that uses permanent vacuum
outstanding yes you have correctly
derived the definition of a permanent
magnetic generator now the way it works
is
this airplane has six permanent magnetic
generators they are the primary source
of flight control power all that has to
happen is the engines have to rotate
that's it so even if the engines are
shut down i can just keep wind going
through the engines and they rotate they
will rotate sufficient to generate power
from the permanent magnetic generators
if those fail the airplane also has
electrical generators on board there's
two of them there's actually three of
them on board they can power the flight
controls as well worst case scenario for
a raptor pilot the engine seize up i
lose my electrical power the only thing
i have left is a battery and just like
anything else battery the more you use
it the more it depletes so at that point
any deflection of the flight control
surfaces depletes the electrical energy
and you don't have that much left to
actually control it
okay one last thing here we'll move on
to the next slide we'll talk a little
bit some just some definitions
um
the wing has this thing on the front you
know what that is what that's called
leading edge flaps right okay perfect
all right
what's that called
ailerons um
now what did i hear i heard something
else
ah
who said that ah okay explain
uh
it's a combination of both flap and
aoron um
flaps are on the outside air line on the
inside and no
they get that backwards yep all the way
around all the way around yep and um
depending on what you're doing a flight
you're in either have full utils control
surfaces or
part of it is dedicated to the flash and
the part is dedicated to being video
runs yeah
standing that's good
in this airplane this airplane has what
ailerons right
so if i want to go right and i move the
yoke right what happens to the ailerons
here in this airplane
sorry i'll put it that way that way
you're setting up so i'm going this way
so this aileron is doing what it's going
um going down right this aileron is
doing a lot
up right
so i'll cut to the chase
these are ailerons these are fl so these
are the flapperons here on the inside
these are the ailerons
in a raptor
those ailerons deflect differentially so
just like you have in a cessna they can
also both deflect up they can also both
deflect down the flaps on the inboard
are flaps and ailerons flaparons so they
can deflect up and they can flect down
we'll show why that brings up some neat
stuff okay
rudder obviously back here
in this airplane when i push the rudder
left the rudder deflects left i deflect
right this has two rudders
both rudders can deflect one way they
can deflect the other way they can both
deflect in and there's some reasons why
you'd want to do that and they can both
deflect out
the last piece i'll give you is back
here normally this would be called an
elevator but on a supersonic airplane we
call these
horizontal stabilators if you guys have
read the story of the bell x1 so chuck
yeager when he went supersonic we talked
a little bit earlier about supersonic
shock waves forming on the airplane as
you start going fast
what chuck yeager discovered is that the
elevator like in a traditional
cessna
that horizontal stabilator does not move
so the elevator at the back moves but
the horse but but this part stays fixed
that shock wave that would form right
here would actually blank the air back
to the elevator and they wouldn't have
any pitch control so when they talk
about this thing called mock tuck which
was a scary scary thing that happened to
a lot of world war ii fighter pilots
when they got into a dive
they would start forming shock waves on
the airplane they didn't have the
elevator authority to pull up and so
they would actually nose dive all the
way in because they go faster and faster
and faster heading down the answer was
rather than the back end of this thing
maneuvering the entire surface moves
so
as a fighter pilot especially when you
got people walking underneath the
airplane because their maintainers are
working on things you always always
always you show them your hands because
if you tap that stick again the stick is
not directly connected just like it is
the stick is connected to a computer the
computer votes and allows things to
happen and then commands a 4000
hydraulic psi system to deflect
basically this big old wing you can
actually take a guy's head off
with the flight control surfaces so you
always always show your hands whenever
you have people walking underneath the
airplane for that
so it's got a very very advanced flight
control system on board we'll talk
through a little bit about what
advantages that kind of gives you
last piece i'll give you is the engines
at the back
which are thing of beauty i was a
propulsion guy aeronautics engineer kind
of thing
it's almost like modern art masterpiece
to me
those engines
are have the ability to call what's
called thrust vectoring they'll swing up
and they'll swing down
where would you want to use that why
does the why do the engines have thrust
vectoring you've answered a lot man
you're smart though you know what's
going on go ahead
very low speeds very low speeds i'm
standing yep where's it where's another
regime
think of the flight envelope of the
airplane
yeah very high very high altitude so so
why high altitudes
a little lift from the wings or the
wings can be
yeah density goes way down as you go up
in altitude so if i deflect this i mean
i have to get more deflection to move
that air to be able to move the airplane
if i'm relying just on the aero surfaces
alone the way i get around that is i put
two 35 000 thrust pound engines if you
will on board the airplane and just like
a fire hose if i grab a fire hose and i
move it you would feel that torque on
your body the same thing here uh with
with the thrust vectoring on the back so
with just the movement of my hand i can
deflect 70 000 pounds of thrust
way at the back end of the airplane so
we talked about center of gravity being
right about here
so that moment arm of that thrust force
is all the way back here and i can
deflect that up and at very very low
speeds where the flight control surfaces
might not be doing well i can still move
the airplane just by using the the
thrust alone at high altitude where i
don't have a lot of density same thing i
can maneuver the airplane just by using
the thrust
alone so where that helps you because
again this is a dog fighter
here's what happens and you'll you'll
see this from time to time so i'll do
this with a side look
when i get to high angle of attack so
the wind is coming like this
and it's hitting the bottom surface of
the airplane um i don't have the ability
to really maneuver a lot because
sometimes some air surfaces are blanked
by just the size of that fuselage coming
right out into the wing so i cheat if
you will by using the engines to get
that final little pitch rate we'll see
later on in the raptor demo video where
the airplane will go it's called a high
alpha loop high angle of attack loop
it'll go vertical
and rather than doing like a loop where
you see it prescribe this whole path
over here the airplane will go vertical
i'll engage the thrust vectoring and
it'll pivot so the velocity vector is
still heading straight up so the
airplane is still moving up but it kind
of does this gymnastics thing where i've
now turned the airplane using thrust
vectoring even though the airplane is
still heading straight up it's wacky
it's totally cool all right
all right let's talk through a couple
other things
okay so that's the flight controls how
we doing timeline okay we're looking
pretty good
okay okay
anyone recognize the cockpit on
your left
f-15 yeah outstanding good
this was my very first airplane i didn't
know any better right i sat down and
said wow what a cool cockpit look at all
these cool stuff buttons everywhere and
switches all over the place
this is an airplane of the 70s
designed when
richard nixon jimmy carter that kind of
era if you will
very very first intro to solid state
electronics really wasn't fully fleshed
out at this stage
this airplane had a hydro mechanical
system which meant that just like in
this airplane where there are cables and
pulleys
the similar kind of flight control
system in it there
this picture is the raptors cockpit on
the inside some pretty dramatic
differences between the two so again
just call them out what do you see
glass cockpit where does that help you
oh yeah it's great you see these new
digital cockpit mercedes benz and bmws
or whatever where like in the old days
you just had you know speed and tack if
you will now you can configure it
however you want
now these become the moment you start
putting that in there
no got it yeah the moment you start
doing stuff like that
you start creating a software
airplane which gives you a lot of
flexibility and a danger right we'll
talk about that one a little bit later
on what else do you see
flight controls why since we're talking
mainly about flight controls today
side stick yeah so
right
there
is the control stick in an f-15 sits
directly between your knees
in a raptor
that is your control stick it's on the
side
why would you ever want to put something
like that on the side go ahead all right
you can't move your head
that's part of it that helps and there's
actually you can't see it here it's
partly there but kind of this little
section here it's a fold out armrest so
your wrist is on the stick your your
elbow is if you will it's resting on an
armrest so it gives you a lot of
leverage from there um that's one reason
what's a couple other reasons why you'd
want to go side stick vice center stick
your legs the way on the finish legs get
in the way that's a big deal um because
in this airplane
you actually got got pretty good after a
while flying it where if you really need
to maneuver the stick you kind of do the
leg up and kind of move over that way to
get everything out of the way um the
other side about it too it might not be
quite so obvious but you see how that
stick that's about where your eye height
would be um you see how that stick kind
of gets in the way of seeing some of the
instruments
so it's just sitting right there right
in a side stick
that's completely off to the side and
all of this real estate is completely
open
the other thing i'll give you again just
for sake of time
it's it's a little bit of a
thought change
when you have a center stick
it's like when you're driving a car
and
when you're at
parking you know you're trying to park
your car you want to be able to maneuver
that wheel around a lot
uh but when you're at highway speeds if
you were to take the wheel and maneuver
it that much again you're going to roll
the car
so
in a center stick
you move the stick around to be able to
deflect the flight control surfaces
there's a physical displacement of the
stick to make that happen on a side
stick that stick initially when they
first put it in
did not move at all so imagine if you
were in your car and you wanted to steer
and rather than the wheel actually
moving you just put pressure on the
wheel itself and that was enough to
transmit to the computer in the car to
turn the wheels
that was a problem initially
which we can talk about after the
presentation that's a little bit of a
sidebar discussion this is a human
factors thing it's a side stick
initially it didn't move eventually they
decided i'll put in some deflection so i
can go a half inch left a half inch
right about a quarter inch forward
because normally
uh
you know i go about a half inch back
because normally i really want to get
the nose going this way if i had that
much deflection forward i don't want to
fly the airplane this way so you have
the ability to do that but it gives you
a little bit of the best of both worlds
there's some deflection to give you
feedback that you've input something on
the stick but not so much deflection
that it kind of gets in the way of
everything else you're trying to do so
there's limited real estate in a fighter
cockpit
uh the last piece i'll give you and it's
a little bit hard to see here is
um
all those buttons there on the stick
uh you know
what you have the ability to do so it's
exactly like modern car car steering
wheels right now you can control volume
radio everything else like that you can
do it from the steering wheel same thing
in a fighter it's called hands-on
throttle and stick hotas and it allows
you to control everything that you would
want to do on the airplane with never
having to leave your your hands from the
throttle on the stick
the other piece i'll give you is that in
a raptor so in a fighter like this this
is your stick this is your throttle in a
raptor because the flight control modes
can change so much this is your right
inceptor and this is your left inceptor
it's all considered part of the flight
control system
all right let's keep going
so
just like on your car where if you want
to go to xm radio you go to media
source or whatever and go xm satellite
radio you have buttons because it's a
software driven jet just like we saw
before and i can pull up a flight
control display that shows me the
position of all my flight control
surfaces again
the pilot is way forward on the front
end of this airplane as i deflect things
sometimes i can't actually see them and
so initially this was a flight test
display so that i don't have to do the
old poltergeist thing and try to rotate
all the way around to be able to see to
the back end of the airplane to see if
the elevator is moving
i basically instrument everything and i
can see it here now some of the human
factor stuff that's kind of cool with
how they did this
so this right here
so again this tells you at the top
rudder deflection surfaces ailerons
where the horizontal stabilators are at
how the engines are doing this is a
little weird i don't really like how
they did this one but this is the
leading edge flaps le flaps or leading
inch flaps so it just shows you how far
they're deflected dug in dug down
on the lower left hand corner it shows
you center of gravity
so there's limits
just like would you you know what you
would normally do on flight planning for
your cessna hey i can only put this much
fuel with this much passengers and i got
to be within this limit for takeoff for
landing and everything else the airplane
tells you that now what's cool about
some of the things they've done in
raptor is that if it's out of limits
again it doesn't expect you to get out
the piece of paper with the whiz wheel
and the e6b it just changes color and it
goes red and it gives you a warning
right and it says hey idiot
you are beyond the aft center of gravity
no gauge tells you it's just having a
hard time seeing where all the fuel is
and everything else that's a different
story but it tells you where what
percentage of mean aerodynamic cord that
you're sitting at
and it's able to adjust stuff around so
i'll give that to you because what this
allows is oh by the way the last part
here is flight control so in other words
this tells you where you've moved your
stick and it tells you trim so you know
where the trim is set and also tells you
where the stick is set so you know your
inputs that kind of go through there
when you have a software driven machine
you can customize things and make it
very simple
you guys have seen that terrible
terrible awful movie top gun right it's
just awful right so that scene where
maverick loses his engines
and they go through this engine one is
out engine two is out and they go on
this flat spin to sea which is a bunch
of bs when you're in a spin you don't
translate over the ground you fall
straight down so this whole flying out
to sea thing is ridiculous it doesn't
happen that way um
in
if you don't have a software driven
airplane when you lose engines like that
then you've got to go through this whole
it's like for instance in the cessna if
you lose a motor lose the motor
what do you got to do right establish
your glide get everything set up check
to see in my left right or both on the
fuel source what's my whatever blah blah
blah and everything else
in the raptor it's the most awesome
thing possible you literally do nothing
you sit there and the computer goes oh
you've lost the motor i've noticed that
you have a problem let me see if i can
help you and it will restart the motor
for you if it can right if if it can't
restart the motor chances are it ain't
going to restart and you can just leave
it shut down if you will
it allows some neat human factor designs
because in this airplane in the raptor
believe it or not when you're flying the
raptor you're not
thinking about flying the raptor you're
thinking about employing the raptor so
you're trying to find where all of your
wingmates are
where the bad guys are etc etc flying is
secondary whereas in this plane flying
is everything
so they tried to as much as possible
alleviate the pilot from as much burden
of responsibility of thinking about
flying the airplane by doing kind of
neat little tricks like that
the other thing i'll give you too about
the flight controls is again we talked
about how
ailerons can go up ailerons can come
down flapper ons go up they go down
rudders come out go down on takeoff mode
i'll show you something kind of cool
so
here's the nose look on here on takeoff
mode without any input from the pilot so
there's no flap switch in the cockpit
there's no leading edge there's nothing
there's nothing like that
it just knows based on the fact that
you've got the gear handle down and that
you're on the ground and it senses the
weight on wheels that thinks this guy
wants to take off so the rudders will
both deflect inward why would you do
that
god
so that needs a shorter runway so um
not quite um there is a tie between the
flight controls though so in other words
if i take the rudders and i tow them
both in so both rudders are deflected in
what does that do from an aerodynamic
standpoint
which way is the nose going to go if
these rudders are deflected in
up right
so it makes it easier to rotate the
airplane on takeoff because the rudders
are deflecting in both of them go in
right uh the other part about it too is
so we talked about this you guys ever
see like a competition aerobatic like
one of those extra 300 kind of airplanes
see how the aileron runs the entire
length of the whole wing so about the
pilot all they got to do is just tap the
wing and the airplane is going to do
corkscrews and spirals on a raptor
that's part of the reason why the
aileron and the flapper on can move
together as one surface and so the
leading edge flaps will dig in the
trailing
aileron and the chilling edge flap that
will dig in as well
so on takeoff
with no input from the pilot
whereas the wing normally
would look sort of like this with a
little bit of camber on it
on takeoff the wing looks like this
it's kind of cool like when you look at
it from the side
so if you're looking at it from
directly side on that leading edge flap
comes down these come down
that puts in a whole bunch of camber on
the wing and it generates a lot of lift
so and again that's completely
independent of the pilot the pilot has
done nothing other than just tell it i'm
on the ground because the gear handle is
down last what's it what would be what
would be a typical rotation speed
yeah so that's a good question what do
you guys think
so i start on the runway by the way i
need 8 000 feet of runway this whole
2500 feet is not for a raptor
unfortunately um 8 000 feet of runway
but by the time i actually get ready to
pull back on that stick to rotate um how
fast you think it's going
i wish
200. well close 150 is a usual usually
so about takeoff weights by the way this
airplane is about
34 or 35 tons
on takeoff compared to like you know
2500 pounds or whatever
so it's a very heavy airplane it's got
to get a lot of speed to be able to get
that rotation but it's about 150 160
knots uh on takeoff which is like faster
than like the never exceed speed of the
cessna
as it goes
but yeah so the flight controls are
there to help you um the other thing
i'll show you too is uh there is so sail
plane guys where am i sail plane guys
fly sail planes so on the left
in a sail plane copper you typically
have a lever for the speed brakes
spoilers right so these big surfaces
that pop up on the wing to slow the
airplane down adjust glide slopes and
those sorts of things
we talked a little bit earlier about how
the electrical engineer guys want this
thing to be completely stealthy and
whatever else the last thing you want to
do based on the discussion we just had
is i don't want to have a big board
stick up in the middle of this airplane
because that's going to make my radar
reflection go very very large so they
did something kind of remarkable they
use the flight control surfaces
themselves
as the speed brakes
so if i need to slow the airplane down i
hit a little switch on the throttle and
immediately what happens is
the leading edge flaps will come down a
bit the ailerons will both go up
the rudders will go out so they'll both
toe out
and it's using that to help slow the
airplane kind of down it's actually
quite effective
which is pretty cool
all right a couple other things we'll go
through
landing mode
pilot's done nothing touchdown throttles
are back
gear handle's down
and all of this stuff happens here let
me get this zoomed in here
so that's the aileron it's up holy crap
the other one's up too
the flapper on goes up on either side
the rudders you can see how they're both
kind of kind of towing in there a little
bit
the reason it's doing that is it's
trying to transfer all of that weight
from the wings and put it into the gear
so it's trying to kill all of the lift
on the wings and transfer that to the
landing gear so that you have the
maximum traction on the wheels as you
hit the brakes as you slow down
also on
refueling
so when you go air refueling there's a
little switch
uh that you open in the jet that opens
up this door that tells the jet that i'm
getting ready to refuel while i'm
airborne when it does that it says this
guy isn't trying to dogfight the
airplane anymore they're trying to get
gas so therefore i don't need all the
full roll capability and everything else
and really what i really want is an
airplane that's really responsive with
its lift and so again no input from the
pilot but the leading edge flaps will
deploy down the trailing edge flaps and
the ailerons will also deploy down again
they're trying to create camber on that
wing this is all digital flight controls
no input from the pilot whatsoever
what would a typical air speed be when
uh doing this air refueling uh this is
about whoops i'm sorry let me go back
one here this is about uh about 300 300
knots or so something like that
um you got to be able to fly so for a
raptor that's kind of slow um for the
tanker airplane that's somewhat fast so
you're trying to find that marriage
where both airplanes have good flying
qualities so that one's not about to
stall and the other one's in full power
trying to catch up to them
by the way the most unnatural act i've
ever done as a fighter pilot is to
connect up my airplane to another
airplane i just never got used to it i
can do it just fine but the whole notion
of
this big boom connecting my airplane to
the big airliner was just really strange
and weird to me
never got used to it
okay some of the limiters so
in an f-15 because we talked to that a
little bit earlier f-15 can you can get
up to 500 600 miles an hour you can take
both hands on the stick you can pull
that stick all the way back and you will
rip the wings off the airplane and you
will turn it into a big ball of metal
cascading down to the ground because you
have overjeed the airplane
again that awful terrible movie top gun
in which tom cruise departs the airplane
and gets into a spin
again you've exceeded some capability of
the airplane and the airplane departs
controlled flight and gets into some
type of uncontrolled situation
on a raptor
there used to be in the pilot operating
manual a little blurb that said quote
you can maneuver this airplane with
quote reckless abandon
and you will not over g the airplane you
will not depart the airplane from
controlled flight they did a
spectacular job uh allowing this
airplane to get right to the edge of
performance but not going over the top
so
one of the neat things that they did
airplanes in a left-hand turn look at
that aileron it's up
look at that aileron it's up
what the crap is going on there
and if you know this one you really do
get the model
because i didn't know this for a long
time
so again just for sake of times i know
we got guys coming in afterwards
center of gravity
the airplane sits right here
in your engineering classes you always
talk about forces acting on the center
of gravity and you kind of take this
whole airplane and you model it down to
a point mass and you say that's what
that's you know for for sake of all the
the you know sum of forces analysis well
in real life uh this is about 43 feet
wide
yeah you can sum the forces through
there but there's forces acting all over
this airplane at different spots think
about here on the wingtip
i put g on the airplane
and this wing tip it's almost like the
wings want to bend up right as i'm
coming down so you put a lot of stress
out on the wingtips so their answer
quite ingeniously was to deflect the
ailerons down when you're at high
maneuvering the way you know you're at
high maneuvering is you can kind of see
these little wispies forming off the
wingtips so
you are creating low pressure that's
another one too you can see the clouds
forming on the front edge of the wing
low pressure
causes that air to condense and so you
make clouds so you know the airplane is
really maneuvering up and an answer to
reduce stress at the wing tips was to
deflect the ailerons up what happens to
the lift out of the wing tips with the
ailerons up
goes down right so it helps to kind of
push those wings back down again so
you're not trying to over stress the
airplane
there are limiters like this all over
the airplane such that you won't over g
the airplane you can't
you know literally you can do anything
you want to this airplane that's what
i'm telling you it's easier to fly a
raptor than it is to fly a cessna
because you really have to pay attention
what you're doing in a cessna in a
raptor i could put my kid in there and
he can do this all day at whatever speed
and nothing bad will happen to the
airplane it's really quite spectacular
how they did that
uh the other part i'll give you here is
some of the command systems so if i'm in
a dog fight and i'm trying to shoot the
other guy i'm going against a
maneuvering target and so the flight
controls transfer over to what's called
a g command system so if i'm maneuvering
at four g's and i let go of the stick
the airplane will stay at four g's and
if i see that the target's maneuvering i
need to go to six g's or seven g's i'll
put that in and the airplane will keep
that so in other words again it's a vote
right i'm not physically connected to
anything i talk to the computer and i
say i want six g's and the airplane does
all types of black magic and sorcery
behind me and lo and behold the airplane
gets to six to seven g's
that really matters when you're in a
high maneuvering kind of situation so it
goes g command
when you're slower i.e on landing and i
want to put that flight path marker
right on that edge of the runway because
that's where i want to touch down right
at the thousand foot markers
then in that scenario i'm not really
cared so much about g command i care
about pitch rate and so it transitions
over to a pitch rate command and if i
put no input on the stick it says zero
pitch rate again blackmagic and sorcerer
will happen behind me the flight
controls will do whatever they need to
do to make sure that my pitch rate stays
at zero so it transitions from one type
of flight control system to the other no
pilot input whatsoever it's just based
off a flight flight command system
all right so let's talk through a couple
of the implications of that and then
we'll go to questions at the end
can you do the flight control video
raptor at the top it's about a minute
and then
bring it up to full screen and hit pause
[Music]
thank you
okay this one is uh full screen and
pause okay and can you go back to the
beginning of it real quick
okay
so
video in cockpit facing out the display
screens is a big no-no
because you could see stuff so we won't
even bother with that but what they did
this is the raptor flight demonstration
team this is out of langley air force
base virginia they mounted a camera in
the cockpit kind of facing aft what i
love about this is again you can see
real quick kind of what's going on with
the airplane so again the leading edge
slats there's no input from the pilot
other than just maneuvering they'll
deploy wherever they need to you'll see
the horizontal stabilizators and if
you're close you can actually see where
the ailerons are doing and what the
flapper ons are doing
a neat trick and we'll see this as they
go into this high g demo
you guys know about have you this gets a
little bit advanced but a thing called
static margin
which is a stability thing about this
airplane again this airplane in its bare
airframe configuration
no hydraulics no computers nothing on
board the airplane totally unstable
what keeps it stable is the computer
itself
what you'll see is you'll see this
maneuver where he'll go into a g turn
and you'll see all the clouds forming on
the back end of the airplane pay
attention to what the leading edge flaps
are doing they're digging in the
horizontal stabilizators
you'll see them initially move to get
the turn going but then once established
in the turn
the way it's controlling things is it's
moving around the aerodynamic center and
the center of gravity it's doing that by
dorking around a bit with the lift on
the wing and it's doing that by
deflecting the leading edge flaps so
that flight control surface display i
showed you earlier the horizontal
stabilizers will be completely
streamlined and all of the maneuvering
is coming from the wing itself which is
pretty amazing
the next video no no go to flight
controls we'll watch that i'll go back
okay yep and then we'll just kind of
watch as it goes through
this time without the funky club music i
guess hopefully
[Music]
horizontal stability
[Music]
[Music]
i know totally
so at that speed again it's a g command
system pilot is commanding a certain g
rate and minor deflections are happening
all the way here back along the back
edge of the airplane pilots has no input
on that
the system is doing everything possible
to command that g that the pilot has
asked for
you'll see one other maneuver here pause
for a second
so what this maneuver is is
and again right slow speed
um airplanes going straight up and what
they're trying to do is basically pitch
forward completely um and get the
airplane so it's almost like you're
flying an l like you're going straight
up and then you want to pitch forward
and then accelerate out horizontally
that way
the way it gets that is through that
thrust vectoring that happens but as
that maneuver happens again all the
pilot is doing is just doing a direct
push forward on the stick watch what
happens to all the flight controls in
the back of the airplane to keep that
airplane going exactly where the air
pilot wants it to play
so you'll see huge deflections out of
that horizontal stabilizator it's kind
of neat you can keep playing
so what you're seeing there is
from the outside of the airplane we'll
see this more on the demo
is
the airplane is essentially pirouetting
in the sky so it's falling straight down
but it's very controllable it's flying
at speeds about 60 to 65 miles an hour
but very very controllable and you'll
see every bit of flight control surface
on the back end of this airplane
deflecting to do what it needs to do so
don't think of it in terms of aileron
elevator
it's a little bit fluid when it comes to
a raptor it's stuff stuff happens back
there touch and go video okay so this
shows a little bit of yeah you can go
and play that
and hit pause for a second we'll just do
this setup
okay so very quick the setup for this
video um this is the downside of a
digital flight control system uh because
on this airplane again it's it's pure
cables pulleys right it's ratios and
gears and
stuff like that right on this airplane
it's software code it's zeros and ones
and you better get it right and
everything is interconnected we talked
about how moving the gear handle tells
the flight control system something
different if i open the air refueling
door it tells the flight control
something different
in this case the power setting of the
airplane
tells the airplane something different
this guy one of my good friends test
pilot outstanding guy so don't think of
this as he's a bad pilot he's not he's
awesome
but the jet believed something that
wasn't really true because there was an
error in how the software was coded and
you'll see the first approach he'll do
an approach
he'll take off again on what's called
military power so they're not using
afterburner
and the airplane behaves just fine on
the next time around he goes around
using afterburner power so you'll see
fire come out of the back end of the
airplane and that changes something in
the flight system for the engines which
tells the flight control computer a
different condition and what ended up
happening is that the gains if you will
of the stick were completely off
so again this would be like if you were
on the highway speed and that same wheel
deflection you would use to park your
car in your garage now that little
deflection of your wheel makes that same
turn of the tires up front so you get
into what's called a pilot induced
oscillation pio which basically says
you're out of phase with the airplane if
i'm driving my car and i turn the
steering wheel right the car's going
left as it's going left i'm trying to
correct that i go right now the thing
goes right and so you get out of phase
with the airplane and you'll see what
happens go ahead and play
by the way you see all the flight
control surfaces deflecting in the back
this is now in a pitch rate system so
he's just trying to land the airplane
the back of the airplane does whatever
it needs to do to keep that flight path
marker exactly where it needs to go
and again all the flight control
surfaces deflected military power
because the engines are black if you
will on this one on the next time around
you'll see him maneuver
with afterburner and you'll see him get
into this pitch-induced oscillation
that's the chase airplane by the way
it's an f-16 that follows them around
so same thing getting set up to land the
camera goes out of focus here for a
second comes back in
again just notice everything that's
happening on the back end of this
airplane to keep that pitch rate where
the pilot has commanded it to
two things will happen here he selects
afterburner and he raises the gear that
changes the flight control laws and the
gains were not set correctly
there's the afterburner and now you see
where he's out of phase with the
airplane
and he's doing everything to keep the
airplane from hitting the ground and
can't avoid it
he's okay
but the airplane was fairly well scraped
up you can imagine
so it's just a danger right the digital
flight controls allow a lot of
flexibility and creativity
there used to be a term it's only
software you know we can figure it out
not true when you're dealing with
you know vehicles like this
where small changes in software code can
have dramatic implications on the
ability of the airplane so it takes an
amazing amount of uh
demo yep you can go into raptor demo and
with that we can go questions because
i'm a little bit over uh
no that's fine okay
so we can play this full speed or a full
full screen if you will
you want to take questions while it's
running yeah so this is from another
good buddy of mine guy named zeke
skelicki who was the raptor demo pilot
outstanding guy
but this is the raptor demo if you've
ever seen it so we'll take some
questions while this is going go ahead
yeah greater than one to one so the
airplane about sixty three sixty four
thousand pounds uh normally a store on
takeoff
the thrust coming out the back is 70
thousand pounds
so on a nice cold day like if you're
close enough to sea level you will
actually go faster than the speed of
sound while you're climbing
up
which is cool
oh yeah try to repeat the question if
you can oh sorry because he's not miked
so the question was uh well one the
question was is thrust weight ratio it's
greater than one to one a little bit
greater than one to one on takeoff
by the way watch this maneuver here real
quick
so that's the thrust vectoring um kind
of kicking in to really get the airplane
so initially that's the flight control
surfaces and then as things slow down
the thrust vectoring kicks in to
basically turn the airplane into a flat
plate
second question was about the thrust
vectoring on takeoff
so it'll put in a little bit up not much
just a little bit up just to help the
nose rotate but just just a tad
this is that high angle of attack uh
kind of maneuver if you will
keep going it's all good questions
yeah you said all the software's written
so basically so the plane can't damage
itself yeah does the pilot become one of
them can it get you in a situation where
it can hurt you yeah very much so in
fact we've kind of achieved that spot
now where the pilot very much is
limiting the performance of the airplane
itself because the airplane can do so
much more
what you so this is what's called a
fifth generation fighter first
generation was like an old korean war
like f-86 kind of airplane and then
successively through the generations you
arrive at this fifth generation which to
me is the pinnacle of what you could get
with a human and an airplane together
sixth generation is going to involve
teaming this airplane with unmanned
airplanes and the unmanned airplanes are
going to have a lot more capability from
a maneuvering standpoint because they
don't have the limitation of the pilot
and all the life support systems that
come with it and everything else so all
that weight you would normally devote to
that you can get away with putting other
stuff in there
when i was telling you fly is about the
same speed as like cessna
i mean this is those types of maneuvers
there where you can get away with that
again watch the flight control surfaces
in the back and what's going on
later on they'll do a pass where he'll
open up the doors and you can see the
main weapon bay which is underneath the
airplane belly and then you'll see the
side weapon bay doors so you can kind of
see kind of where all the weapons are
carried inside the airplane again a huge
center of gravity challenge incidentally
so so here's that maneuver so you can
see the doors open
one thing i didn't really tell you about
is so in that situation because you know
missiles weigh a couple hundred pounds a
piece or so some of the bombs are about
a thousand pounds a piece when you lose
all that weight immediately it's
literally like dropping a car off the
front end of your airplane the way that
it fixes that center of gravity issue is
by changing fuel inside the airplane so
it sloshes fuel forward or back to keep
the center of gravity again completely
pilot there's no fuel control panel
where i go we'll move this and click
this and whatever it does it all
completely automatically go ahead
yeah
the sensors that you can use so all of
the fuel tanks are are instrumented um
so you know the status of fuel in terms
of where things are set up um it you
tell it what actually it has the ability
to know what's on the airplane so when
you load a missile it goes oh it's this
type of missile and it goes it weighs
this much and it knows the mass
properties of it and so it sets it up
from there
um so
it actually identifies that all by
itself
so like in a in a cirrus you have to go
you have to actually pull up a screen in
the cirrus and go my passenger weighs
this and i've got this baggage on board
and then it gives you the picture of
where the center of gravity is
this thing because it's all digital the
missile has a little connector rod that
connects in and it says ah behold i'm a
missile oh the pilot weight doesn't
matter uh because they
they expect it
well
it matters but for a different reason it
matters for the ejection seat
predominantly because the ejection seat
um you know i think it's like 135 pounds
is the light it's something like that
11535
to like 220 or something it's something
around that spot um so to be able to be
within the safe envelope of the ejection
seat that's where the weight of the
pilot matters um
but they they spec the center of gravity
such that so long as
really anyone can sit up front and
you're not going to throw off the cg of
the airplane even though you're way far
forward of the of the cg and there
there's a moment arm there but between
everything else in the cockpit i mean
that ejection seat is ridiculously heavy
and all the avionics that sit up front
the radars up front i mean all these
things that sit up there have far more
of a contribution to the center of
gravity than you do
unless you're like shaq or something
like that but god
on the either flight cockpit or on the
helmet screen
so in this airplane not yet uh that's
coming along soon some of the older
airplanes believe it or not have that
like the f-15 that i flew you had a
special helmet that had all of the
information displayed on the visor
itself
so in addition to that hands on throttle
and stick so i don't have to take my
hands off of anything to touch anything
in the cockpit i also don't have to look
in the cockpit to see altitude air speed
heading it's all displayed to me
up front
this airplane eventually will get that
it it didn't make the this is a
programmatic discussion now right they
only had so many dollars to spend and
they said this airplane is so awesome
that it shouldn't need a helmet mounted
display system because it should be able
to see
all the bad guys from far enough away
and not be a problem
we fielded the airplane that way and
every pilot you so the first batch of
pilots they all transitioned from
airplanes that had that helmet
helmet-mounted system and they came to
this airplane where it didn't have it
and they were pissed they're like we we
got to have that back right so that's
kind of where a lot of the efforts now
are going to modernize the airplane a
bit
what else good questions go ahead yeah
uh we still need humans in the cockpit
why not just go for unmanned systems
yeah
it is it is the great debate of the
fighter community right now and you're
really touching on something really
really deep
um
the best answer so far is that the
greatest i mean we talked a lot about
the hardware and the systems onboard the
airplane really the greatest piece of
capability on the airplane is the mind
of the person flying
up front if it's a very dynamic and
changing environment
to be able to tell a machine to be able
to incorporate all those inputs and make
the right decisions based on that
kind of hard to do right now i'm not
saying we're not going to get there just
right now it's it's difficult
where we use unmanned systems a lot now
is like in surveillance
missions where you can just launch the
thing and it's got a pre-programmed
navigation and it knows what it needs to
do and it can set things up
those are
somewhat bounded problems probably the
best way to describe it where you could
use an unmanned system for that work
it's difficult is in combat situation
it's it's extremely dynamic it's it's
battle royale wwf mosh pit any possible
chaotic situation you can put that's
kind of what it looks like
and so having a human mind attached in
that environment to be able to adapt and
do what the mind does better than a
machine does at least right now that's
the main argument to keep humans in the
system
for now right there's a follow-up on
that yeah
to remotely operate them yes it is the
timeline
it is um
yeah the question is is that if you
operate these things remotely so even if
you had so you know classic example
we'll use sully sullenberger right as we
talked about sully in the previous one
you take off out of laguardia you lose
both engines if you could have a remote
pilot sitting somewhere else that could
take over and decide land on the hudson
because a machine most likely wouldn't
have made that choice
is there a time lag issue the answer is
100 yes
there is a time lag issue between
getting that information displayed down
make the input that input goes back up
and comes back over
a thing we've done at test pilot school
is remember we showed earlier that
flight path marker uh where as a pilot
you put the flight path marker and
that's exactly where your airplane is
going to go if there's a time lag that
will actually mess you up because
there's some second or two delay between
what you're seeing and what the
airplane's actually going at test pilot
school they actually built a flight test
or flight path marker that accounts for
that time delay if it knows that time
delay it'll actually account for it so
you could fly the airplane remotely
even with the time lag and still be able
to do very high gain tasks like land the
airplane for instance where things are
changing very rapidly so it's a new
science not fully fleshed out here but
the proof of concept has been
demonstrated to control an airplane
remotely
even with the time lag
who really cares about that right now
are the airlines
because to be very frank the pilots tend
to be a pain in the butt for an airline
company
and if you can remove the pilots and
just have a remote operated system or
even an autonomous system uh to the from
a business standpoint the company really
likes that from an aviation standpoint
it triggers all types of discussions and
a lot of other issues um but that's one
question good let me jump let me jump in
for a minute with that i think actually
to me one of the holy grails of ga
safety
would be to have
uh a
uh
human co-pilot perhaps you know on the
ground so if you had that kind of
telemetry that you have in a in a drone
uh you know human somewhere else could
say you know you're running a little
short on fuel or you forgot to change
tanks all the things that human
co-pilot could do right in the cockpit
you know most of that safety running
checklist could be probably enhanced
remotely so that would be a great add to
a cessna or a piper even and you see a
little bit now in some of the more
advanced airplanes like we talked a
little bit about if i have an engine
problem in the raptor i literally do
nothing i just sit there and stare at
the clouds and go wow what a lovely day
and the computer fixes it for me right
there are other scenarios where the jet
will tell me hey you've got a generator
problem and then immediately pull up the
checklist
for the generator failure to allow me to
fix it so you see some basic automation
right now kind of already in play a
couple other questions i know we're
running short guys
how much a flying raptor is seat of the
pants that you would miss by not being
in cockpit by not being there so
automated at this point that it's the
same whether you're sitting there
yeah if it's a uh so it's we have two
terms one's called beyond visual range
which means i can't see the other guy
with my eyes
but my sensors can see him um and if i'm
shooting missiles long distance like
that i don't lose any seat of the pants
by being remotely it's like a video game
like literally it's exactly like a video
game um if it's a maneuvering
environment where i see the guy and
we're in a dogfight then yeah you lose a
lot right in terms of seat of the pants
eyeball just things that are hard to to
automate so it's
half and half right in a drone scenario
i mean
would a drone dogfight i don't know it's
a good question i'm not really sure
god to address that could you just have
a simulator
you could um but then i have to have
some way to represent the physical
environment that the drone is seeing i
got to be able to represent that to
the guy in the simulator on the ground i
have to be able to kind of relay that
real time um it matters so uh
who plays sports right guys you know any
i mean whenever you're playing sports
you got an opponent uh you get if you
play a lot like if it's racquetball or
football or something like that you get
very good at looking at your opponent
and being able to see micro movements
before the actual big movement happens
so that you know oh they're about to
swing this way or they're going to throw
this way so you can read your opponent
and make a decision about what's about
to happen a second or two from now in a
fighter jet the exact same thing if i'm
fighting a guy and i see a control
surface deflection even before the
airplane is gone i know
person's going this way
i can position myself to be there before
they arrive
i would need some way to represent that
if i'm in a simulator on the ground and
it would have to be kind of transparent
to the guy in the simulator
what that feels like
lots of good questions it's good class
let me ask actually where's who's here
from the flying club
uh sebastian yeah yeah actually i wonder
if les can you stay another uh 10 15
minutes absolutely why don't we have
sebastian jump in give us flying club
spiel
and then both of them will be up front
for uh questions right afterwards
thank you liz no worries
you